séquence phase calme première la
dernière fois je réfléchissais comme ça
tout seul parce que j'ai pas d'amis et
je me disais tiens y'a pleins
d'inventions comme ça qu'ils peuvent pas
exister mais qui pourtant serait bien
pratique dans la vie de tous les jours
on pourrait appeler ça les inventions
imaginaire par exemple un truc qui
serait pas mal ça serait un bouton de
volume mais carrément sur les gens car
ces mutins pour tous les fans moi je
suis gay de france battu par canal du
midi et la voilà donc j'étais vraiment
sur la piste en chasse neige c'est tout
me maggio rôle lui c'est parce qu'il y
est eu un destin bémont gastal ou alors
juste un mode silencieux sur les bébés à
l'eau une sorte de gps qui donnerait le
meilleur chemin pour esquiver les gens
roulent ou dans cinq mètres tournez à
gauche pour esquiver nicklas corto le
relou du collège qui va vous parler
pendant trois heures alors bonnes tu te
rappelles de moi nicolas portant à 5 md
mais on était ensemble en cours on se
défie de prout ensemble un
simplificateur d'explication un truc qui
simplifierait tous les trucs trop long
et trop chiant en raison des ayants
droit de votre contrat si vous
souscrivez notre assurance le taux
d'intérêt sera indexée sur thoune 3 % et
pas enrôlé cette embrouille et pour
cuisines des trucs qui vont rapporter un
maximum de tune aouate donc soit tu es
un gros con et tu signes jeter un petit
peu mal en tout cas voilà simplement une
sorte de bracelets électrique à faible
puissance anti morin gare pour la mecque
à ce soit en ce une petite soirée à
l'hawaiienne là qu'est ce qui m'arrive
et je me sens tout flagada renouer qui
m'a mis ça c'est vraiment un truc de
nounours ah ça commence à me les briser
menu
ok j'ai compris ok faut dire que des
mots à la mode swag un anti spoiler
automatique tu regardes washington ouais
je fonde en recevant l'ours est sérieux
j'ai le dernier épisode hier c'est ouf
mêmes qui meurt je m'y attendais pas du
tout c'est pas au nom bien qu'une tumeur
llagonne tu meurs meurs totalement il
décède une application qui serait un
chat âmes mais des visages d'asile tient
bien sa peine de mort
oui c'est me frôlent ou ne jamais parler
un truc qui serait très pratique pour
nous les gens qui ont des décerne de me
mettre un outil six pattes heures
d'insomnie redit tout le monde mon coach
et vous allez faire une insomnie de deux
heures en pensant à des trucs badens
tels que votre ex la mort ou encore au
nombre d'entrées de votre film pas très
normal activités redresse à un petit peu
avec vous bonsoir uno ou sinon une sorte
d' inventions on pourrait directement
faire des screenshots mais dans la vraie
vie c'est un truc que tu kiffes du
screen direct toi norman ça faisait déjà
ça s'appelle une photo ce qui serait
vraiment cool ce serait une télécommande
de télé parlante et ou [ __ ]
télécommande aller où es tu
salut ça va ouais ça va mais merde ça
fait trois jours que je crois que c'est
derrière coussins et en plus j'ai la
voix de louis murphy mais j'ai une
question à se poser est ce à quoi on
fait tous tes boutons à les boutons là
une sorte de radar qui te dirai
directement ou exactement dans le monde
se trouvent la femme de ta vie à elle
est par là
les femmes de ma vie j'arrive
hambourg
et donc elle a d'accord donc une femme
girafe à ckoi je vais installer dender
ça serait génial si j'arrivais à
inventer pour de vrai l'hoverboard
normal c'est que déjà en fête ah oui il
faudrait qu'on arrête aussi d'appeler
ses goûts et sans guidon d over board
1,7 pas du tout pareil jeu désolé
je peux essayer une fois une fois vous
n'êtes pas d'adultes un devis nateur de
cadeaux mon coeur cette fois j'ai pas pu
me tromper c'est sûr c'est exactement ce
que tu veux à nouveau mais canon mais
alors là c'est parfait merci
en plus il a pas d'option je crois qu'il
est mature attentionné il est pas radin
il fait des efforts cd non mais c'est
exactement ce que je voulais oh [ __ ]
ça fait plaisir
bonjour voilà j'espère que vous avez
qu'il fait une petite invention
imaginaire alors certes n'ai pas d'amis
mais au moins j'ai des idées inutile je
suis hyper content parce que vous êtes
bientôt 7 millions d'abonnés sur ma
chaîne youtube
on est vraiment très bientôt là on est
vraiment sur le fil merci beaucoup
et au fait qui dit 2016 dit
je recommence la tournée des zénith avec
mon spectacle norman sur scène en 2016
dans toute l'europe francophone en
france en suisse et en belgique
j'ai déjà hâte d'y retourner de vous
revoir dans les zéniths ça va vraiment
être cool à très bientôt en vidéo ou en
vrai ciao
je paniquais l'ambiance plaît laissez
pas tout à fait finie c'est celle heure
de paris maintenant je crois qu'elle a
adoré son cas de monga écoute je suis
hyper content de moi pour une foire est
déjà assurée